just hours ago President Trump touched
down in Honolulu Hawaii making a
stopover as part of his 12 day five
country trip to Asia aside from the
issue of immigration President Trump was
largely elected on his promise to
renegotiate trade deals that have really
hurt American workers as such one of the
most important jobs in the Trump
administration and especially on this
presidential tour of Asia is the US
Trade Representative the man who
currently holds that job is ambassador
Robert light Heiser he sat down with me
for a rare interview yesterday at the
White House ambassador light highs are
great to see you I know you love giving
media interviews so thank you so much
for spending time you are off to Asia
it's a big trip it's the longest trip
the presidents have has ever taken since
he was inaugurated what's what's the
goal this is a very important trip it
has two elements one in security and
geopolitics and the other is a trade and
economic issues I'm obviously concerned
about the second we're going to - to
Japan to Korea to China to Vietnam and
in the Philippines and that would be 65
billion dollar deficit 27 billion dollar
deficit 350 billion dollar deficit 32
billion dollar deficits and in the
Philippines we don't have a lot of
Craiglist we have essentially balance
trade on a small volume so there are a
lot of economic issues a lot of trade
issues the biggest one of course it's
China purely on it on the China front
what can we do other than impose tariffs
to stop the Chinese cheating on these
international trade whether it's dumping
whether it's subsidies of major
corporations selling products for under
market value well I mean we have to have
a coordinated effort within the
administration I think we do first of
all the geopolitics is somebody else's
problem I'm going to focus very much on
on working men and women and farmers
that's what I was hired to do and that's
what I'm gonna worry about
China has an industrial policy that
involves a lot of subsidies a lot of
dumping a lot of forced technology
transfer all these sorts of things so
what have we done we've we have
prosecuted cases on any dumping on
countervailing duty the president has
initiated a case on so-called 301 which
looks at the the intellectual property
train which they call a cold war-era
relic the quote free traders criticized
you and the administration for using
this outdated federal statute to go
after China okay it's a very effective
tool will use the WTO when we can the
president's willing to act unilaterally
when he has to and when we say it's
called rolled air look at Ronald Reagan
used it and he used it very effectively
and it made a big difference for our
trade policy and a lot of people
benefited from it so we'll use every
tool we can as long as it's as long as
it's fair and consistent with law China
has something called their 2025 project
it's their focus to dominate every major
industry from 3d printing to rare earth
to a heavy manufacturing tool
manufacturing it's really ambitious is
it just kind of pie in the sky thinking
or is there a real opportunity for China
to dominate all those industries it's a
very very serious challenge not just to
us but to Europe Japan and the global
trading system and basically it's very
focused it is the areas you talked about
but also aerospace on new energy
vehicles I mean this is they want to be
on top of all the high tech all the
cutting cutting-edge economic I mean
they're doing something that's in their
interest and that they should do we
should be in a position to defend
ourselves with the same amount of vigor
and I think that this president will do
but that is a genuine threat it's a
combination of massive subsidies of
closed markets and so it's a very very
serious threat to in all of those areas
and if you go through the parts of our
economy that are affected by it it's
hard to find any kind of a tech part
that's not potentially adversely
affected by this there's a split in this
party there has been for a long time but
before Trump came along it was Buchanan
and Ross Perot and Mike Huckabee and
Rick Santorum the blue-collar
conservatives do you have any doubt in
your mind about Trump winning because of
his position in part on immigration and
in part on trade would he have won
Pennsylvania or Ohio do you think if he
didn't have that focus on the American
workers I think I think he focused on
what we used to call Reagan Democrats
and now they're really Trump Democrats
they're working men and women and
they're farmers I think he focused on
him I think he is very empathetic this
is a man who goes out there and sees
what is happening to these people and
their communities he cares very deeply
personally I think it was a major major
effect one of the two or three probably
most important things and I think he
believes that and I think he's going to
deliver on his promises we're going to
change this paradigm businesses say we
need the market certainty we need the
certainty or we can't operate and you
say what they're really saying is we
need the certainty so that we can invest
in Mexico so we can out so we want a
certainty an outsourcing my reaction to
that is that's not my job
my job is trying to create manufacturing
jobs in America and to put upward
pressure on people's wages these people
in America many of these workers haven't
had a raise in ten years and and and
they deserve a break and the last thing
we should be doing would be ensuring
guaranteeing subsidizing investments in
another market it makes no sense and by
the way in the case of automobiles
eighty percent of those cars eighty
percent of shift back to America
so wait that so they're so they're
manufactured in Mexico shipped here with
no tariffs shipped here with no chair
that's precise is the idea are you
stunned at this point that after the
president wins after Donald Trump wins
in November of last year almost a year
ago
we are still saying seeing the same
arguments made in the Wall Street
Journal by the Chamber of Commerce by
the Cato Institute that he is acting in
a protectionist manner that he's trying
to put up walls to trade walls to people
in the free market the free flow of
goods and services is going to be hurt
an American sumers consumers are gonna
be hurt the more aggressively we pursue
this trade enforcement they're still
making those arguments well I mean if
you say am i surprised now I mean those
arguments have worked very well for them
for years and years and years and years
of years here is the reality the reality
is the president wants efficient markets
the president wants open fair reciprocal
balanced trade but we don't have
everybody knows that so the question is
what do you do do you buy a rabbit's
foot cross your fingers make the sign of
the Cross I do that or do you have a
strategy where you're going to use every
tool America has to ensure that our
workers and our farmers get a get a fair
shake so when they say you're gonna
start a trade war you say we're not
starting a trade word off we are we have
exactly the same objective as the
Chamber of Commerce exactly the same
objective the question is how do we get
there we've tried it their way we've
tried it their way for 25 years since at
least 1995 we've tried it their way all
I am saying is let's try a different
route for a little
the result of their way I would suggest
is a 750 billion dollar goods deficit
and an overall goods and services
deficit of five I mean these are
staggering numbers we ought to try
something else I think we're going to
end up with more efficiencies we're
going to end up with more it's going to
be fine for businesses but most
importantly it's going to be fine for
American workers and American farmers
who need a break and part of this whole
trade idea this whole public contract is
that we give fair trade and return for
open markets and that's what all the
workers bought into and now they really
haven't got it but with this president I
think they're going to get it tell me
about the president's leadership style
on this particular issue on at least my
area
he knows the stuff and if you look at
his life for 30 years you go back he'll
say exactly the same thing he said 30
years ago 20 years ago 15 years ago
it's embassador life hi sir thank you so
much for spending some time it was my
pleasure